[Music]
we're talking about House of Lies your
character you dance you get to you get
to dance I've got some dance moves that
I didn't show on house of lives that I
usually bring out on the dance floor
that are prime
well like you do the stewardess and
there's like a series of moves I don't
know if I can get a beat from anybody
gonna be like if we like masks masks
seatbelt seatbelt
I love that that's great oh this is a
good one so this one's kind of you if
you make eye contact with someone from
across then I walked in the room and
you're like I got it and if you give me
another beat this is called the Baker
peep this and then I could come over and
be like she was like that's old drywall
jumping his new dance the diabetic